well we are in for a warm easter weekend
if you plan on hitting the pool
public safety crews reminding everyone
be extra careful
extra vigilant with young children
around water bianca holmen has some
important things to remember
well with kids on spring break and temps
in the 90s many of you are probably
cleaning out your backyard pool
but before the first splash here are
some things you want to keep in mind to
keep everyone safe
now drowning is a leading cause of death
in small children
fire officials tell us drowning
accidents are preventable
with the three p's so here they are the
first is patrol an adult should be
watching children at all times in
any type of body of water not just the
pool that includes bathtubs
also protect the pool area with a
barrier or a gate
and then prepare put your child in
swimming lessons or as an adult
take a cpr class it takes just a few
seconds
all too often we hear i had to go and
answer the doorbell i had to answer a
phone call i looked away for just a few
moments
these little ones are adventurous and if
those uh in the movies you see the
splashing and the screaming
the reality is these are silent
terrifying
terrifyingly silent events where a child
in just a matter of seconds can slip
below the water
we're told parents should even be more
alert around pools without lifeguards
such as apartment complex or backyard
pools
and unfortunately we have learned that
just this year there have been two
reported drownings
bianca holman 8 news now